-Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, President Biden says
that he plans to run
for re-election in 2024.
Meanwhile,
at a rally this weekend,
President Trump
also hinted at running.
It's big news, but all I can
think about is Taylor Swift
being on the show tonight, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So you know what that means.
It's time for
"The News: Taylor's Version."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-So, Biden and Trump are both
running for re-election,
and they've got major
"bad blood,"
which everyone knows
"all too well."
Of course, Trump has quite
the "reputation."
Every other day, he's like,
"I did something bad,"
and Biden has to be like,
"This is why we can't have
nice things,"
which is why this could be
the most dramatic election
ever -- more --
Importantly --
"Evermore" importantly,
they both need running mates.
Biden is looking at Kamala like,
"You belong with me,"
while Trump is looking
at Mike Pence like,
"We are never ever
getting back together."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Like, ever.
Pence is actually considering
a run of his own,
but everyone is like,
"I forgot that you existed."
[ Laughter ]
"Long story short,"
everyone is tired of politics.
But, hey,
"you need to calm down,"
"shake it off,"
and get "ready for it,"
because "'tis the damn season."
So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go get your voting "card again,"
head to the polls --
Yeah, that was a stretch,
that one.
Head to the polls and fill in
every "blank space."
It doesn't matter
if you're blue or "red"
or even a "lavender haze."
You've got to let your voice
be heard,
both in 2024 and during
the midterms in "'22."
This has been
"The News: Taylor's Version."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪